what do you think is the best way to
cook a steak i've taken three rib eyes
and prepared them three different ways
we're going to eat each one and figure
it out we're using two inch pieces of
meat and they're quite nice and here
you're searing it first and then putting
in the oven putting it in the oven and
then searing it and then just relying
entirely on the pan this is the
traditional pan fry and then put it in
the oven to finish it off i just
seasoned it with salt and pepper you
don't want to do too much to it because
if you've got a really nice piece of
meat you want to eat what you pay for
you don't really want to mess with it so
you're creating a crust and then
reaching a doneness in the middle that
you prefer right i think in terms of
margin of error pan frying and then
putting it in the oven is the most
difficult and you pan sear the steak but
you don't cook it all the way and then
you put it in the oven to raise the
temperature of the middle and then you
have to take it out of the oven and let
the steak sit for about 10 minutes with
all the steps it's very easy to overcook
your steak if you're not careful right
well this one you just have a much
larger area of well doneness around the
exterior
steaky let's eat these steaks
you're not gonna wait for me it's very
rude
i guess we can only really tell once we
cut all of them let's dive into the pan
fry pan fry according to gordon ramsay
on youtube is the best way to cook a
steak and that's probably the way to go
if you're using a one-inch piece of meat
being done in the pan for a little bit
longer there's a harder caramelization
of the fat and that may be having a
slight effect on the flavor i don't have
a meat thermometer at home they kind of
intimidate me i don't like poking the
meat
if you're straight pan frying it you can
touch it and you can feel how well it's
cooked i think the edges of this one are
crispier yet the inside feels more
tender this also tastes juicier i think
i prefer this one
i think this one has a more delicious
texture the sear and then oven that well
done perimeter
really has an effect on the overall
texture and i don't think it's better i
spoke to a few state connoisseurs they
were very adamant that if you're not
grilling it reverse sear is the best way
to go how do you reverse sear you take
the steak and you season it and you put
it in the oven at a low temperature and
then you sear it for about a minute each
side it's in the oven for 40 minutes so
you're taking a lot of the moisture out
of the surface so it looks like it's a
harder crust you're raising its
temperature so slowly there's a greater
window for you to check it and get it
right the reverse sear method you don't
really need to let it sit because it's
done cooking the entire steak is evenly
cooked right easier way to get the best
results most of the time if you don't
have a meat thermometer i think it's a
little trickier one thing i notice about
the reverse here is that the transition
to pink is a lot smoother this one feels
richer like a wealthy person
would have this this is medium rare the
whole way except for the crust whereas
here you got a lot more variation it
also looks like a bullseye almost the
reverse seer is more refined this is
like
a cowboy
and this is the great gatsby
[Music]
so do you fancy yourself a cowboy or the
great gatsby i'm more great gatsby i
think i'm a little more cowboy cowboy
just seems
lower effort i think both the pan-seared
and the reversier are better than the
sear and then oven but i don't know that
i could say that either that one of
these is clearly better than the other i
don't think i would be disappointed with
any of them really it's only eating them
back to back that i notice a difference
you hold your fork weird
[Music]
oh yes